in this video I'm making the biggest
sculpture I have ever attempted a giant
life-size monster
oh my God that's sick he's a big lad um
I'm a little intimidated I'm not gonna
lie this video is sponsored by
Hearthstone Mercenaries
this is Monster clay this is my favorite
clay and sculpture medium we start off
in a solid form and as you can see it
turns into a full on liquid it's really
malleable and you will come to see how
cool it is as we sculpt grommash
Hellscream from the warcraft franchise I
want to face here matters any human
would and if I wet my pants then that's
a job well done first thing to do when
sculpting is to start with an Armature
so usually when you do an Armature you
do it with what's called Armature wire I
don't think this stuff will be strong
enough at the size of a life-size
skeleton which is why I bought a
life-size skeleton
what better reference to the human scale
than a human
I can explain actually this is a really
good timing Rob has prepared for me a
mood board grommash hell scream that'll
be very useful thank you rob
oh thank God somebody got me out of the
bag now I need to raise his width it's
gonna take a lot to fill out the
Armature this isn't even close yet but
it's just the bare bones so time to LEAP
into making the biggest Armature I've
ever made the whole reason I got the
skeleton so I had something much more
substantial to build out from but the
proportions were all wrong so I fixed
that up by putting a rod through the
Torso after cutting the upper arms short
and securing those to the rod with
Armature wire run through it secured it
all up as much as possible with more
Armature wire
next this guy's looking like a bit of a
skinny Skelly boy and I needed to pack
him out now with previous homages I just
did this with foil and Armature wire to
shape it all up but this guy's far too
big so while I've never used it before I
thought I'd pack the Middle with big
chunks of foam cut to size we're really
expanding the proportions out here in
our orcish way I had to widen the
shoulders and to really make them look
powerful his head has to be higher and
his neck thicker and taller so that
means removing the head sorry buddy I
mean hey at least I've got bragging
points I could tell people I was the one
who beheaded brahmash Hellscream
thank you
[Music]
style looked pretty epic especially when
you look at it from like low angles look
at that oh my God and then when we
raised him like already like I can't
work on him without him already being
taller than me but put him up another
foot or two and I think it's going to be
imposing to finish off the Armature
stage I'm gonna wrap this baby in foil
and wire which will enable me to be a
little more specific about how I bulk
out certain areas but then also the wire
gives it something to grip to because
otherwise the clay would just sort of
slowly slide off
foreign
[Music]
after all that I finally had the
Armature I initially pictured a lot of
foil a lot of Armature wire and there's
magical stuff I found in the studio I
know what it's called it's like this
craft aluminum mesh stuff and it serves
a purpose pretty much halfway between
foil and Armature wire it holds its
shape really well super malleable you
can just tear it up probably should do
this with gloves because it did cut up
my figures a little bit but on top of
the shape ability and the flexibility of
it it's obviously a wire mesh which
means it's got a lot of tooth and
grabability for the clay to stick to
which will hopefully provide the perfect
starting surface for my monster clay
[Music]
yes oh look at that it's like peanut
butter when you take the lid off you're
like oh this is going to be good and
you're like you take the first scoop
this takes a while to heat up into a
liquid form and the reason I'm wearing
gloves is it gets hot I want it to be
quicker because I'm impatient so I've
got more microwaves all right it's been
six minutes we're just gonna check in if
I just push down
oh there you go we're popping up we've
got liquid happening it's not quite
fully liquid yet is it eight minutes
I think it's eight minutes solid on the
surface and on the edges but as soon as
in fact there's like a film of solid on
top and inside is just hot clay liquid
oh God oh God I can't contain it oh no
oh no so I need to try and keep it on
keep it on stay on stay on don't you
drip
so that's what it looks like with one
type of monster clay I have 20 more and
I bloody hope it's going to fill the
rest all of a sudden it feels like 20
tubs may not be enough I have these
amazing references of what I'm going to
be trying to create this is gromash
Hellscream from the warcraft Universe
one of the many amazing characters in
Hearthstone mercenaries as I mentioned
Hearthstone mercenaries is sponsoring
this video which I'm super excited about
for those of you who don't know
Hearthstone is a deceptively simple and
insanely fun fast-paced strategy card
game from Blizzard Entertainment build
your deck start a game and play your
cards to sling spells summon creatures
and Commander Heroes of Warcraft into
jewels of Epic strategy our Hearthstone
mercenaries is a brand new game mode in
Hearthstone combining roguelike and RPG
elements into Hearthstone which you
already know and love it's an entirely
new way to play and master Hearthstone
create a team of mercenaries using
well-known characters and set out on a
bounty you'll need to strategize and
play your cards right and once you hand
it in you can claim your rewards and
upgrade your mercenaries or unlock new
mercenaries to use in your team it even
has a PVP mode for you hardcore players
out there go check out the Hearthstone
mercenaries so stoked that they're
sponsoring this video way excited to be
sculpting grommash Health screen but
beyond that it's just a universe full of
incredible art awesome lore and
characters and you can experience that
in hearts in the series but in the
meantime I have to try and make this
look like this
I've got a lot of work to do
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
making good progress quite a challenge
in a number of ways Clay is either
scolding hot where it's easy to work
with but drips a lot then when it's in
its best state it's like taffy and it's
really hard work to move around and push
and pull then it gets harder and I can't
pull my fingers apart it's a workout but
he's a big boy
while it's not wires to backtrack to the
Armature at this point I can't add more
clay under here without it drooping and
then potentially falling it's
asymmetrical and that really bothers me
so I'm gonna have to cut about or maybe
a bit higher so I get to the Armature
cut it short and then pack under have
something a bit more even so if I go
maybe there isn't so much work I'm
afraid of hard work and in fact you
should subscribe so much cool stuff plan
and this is the second Major Video in
our new studio so much to come so join
in the fun
foreign
the gods of symmetry have been appeased
oh no see what I was talking but that's
okay because it doesn't have to have as
much anymore that's so funny and I can't
work on this until it sets more because
obviously a little droopy at the moment
but it's problem solved huh
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so I've just finished the blocking uh
literally in some places because his
chin kept sinking as you saw at the time
lapses and the further into this I've
gone the happier I am that I did a lot
of that initial blocking with giant
chunks of foam because this is heavy and
there's a lot of it and I've got three
tubs left I'm confident I can take it
all the way to the end as you can see
it's pretty freaking big how comes the
satisfying bit I'm going to take this
very rough blocked orc start to shape
and refine him with his anatomy and
details to gromash
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blood pressure
going up Elevate watch me demonstrate
I grind celebrate no pump fake hesitate
I've been scoring Every Day Champagne
perriers
[Music]
but this one who's always greater Grease
oh hey this is grommash so far I have to
say the last couple of hours have really
lifted my spirits because uh you can
flash back to what he looked like not
too too long ago his uh he had a long
way to go but he's starting to look like
grommash and we're actually getting
supplies where I can add details but I'm
super stoked with my idea of adding ping
pong to the eyeballs to make them pop
out like that it makes me think what
else we could do to just give it that
little bit of edge so that the whole
thing is in clay Gareth had a great idea
doing white resin teeth because
obviously the the big fangs of the Orcs
would just look so cool if it just
really popped out so I'm going to give
that a go see if I can print some in
resin overnight and I also wondered
about hair we have a couple of wigs I'm
not sure how well they'll work but I
just I have to try Okay so this is uh
this is Aussie Surfer grommash
this is the Ronald Weasley grumash this
is everything I hoped it would be and
more Bob Ross grandma
[Music]
no okay we're just experimenting we do
have a long hair black wig and grommash
has long black hair might stand a chance
what do you reckon I feel like I might
we were doing this as like a joke this
is kind of cool I think this will
actually work I can't believe it okay I
think I'm doing the wig we're just gonna
take off the glisten I'm not sculpting
the hair saves a bit of time as I can
focus on some of the other details print
the teeth this is going to be one of the
coolest things I've ever made
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this isn't the only crazy huge and
incredible thing that we made in this
studio this week we built the entire
Lions Pride Inn it's freaking huge it's
fully furnished in the interior the
whole team in the studio put into the
project so go check that out over on
tabletop time and this is this is my
best sculpture this is my favorite
sculpture I've ever made you know what
comes next epic reveal shots yeah how do
we move it
can't you just lift it
oh my God
yeah no he's not going anywhere can we
make it look cool here yeah yeah we have
a green screen upstairs
this way we'll pretend that it's not
night time and we're not working late
it's because it's 9pm but don't let them
know that that's how hard we work to
make the coolest videos possible
it's fine all the way down there yeah no
it's fine
ah you make him look good what do you
want me to do you know what to do
foreign
uh can you make him look good he did you
made him look good
that was how good was that guys no
kidding it's past midnight and it's
gareth's birthday yay
happy birthday Gareth what a freaking
Legend uh this video is not over yet
because uh I have to come in tomorrow
and see what the other guys think of
Grandma's taking his he's taking the day
off taking it out for his birthday well
earned my friend happy birthday
so it's the next day uh grommash is
ready to show off and I've got a few
people in the studio I want to get their
impressions in person
he's pretty big so I'm hoping to get a
bit of a reaction out of people I'm
gonna guide you come back
come back this is a blind date right
foreign
I didn't expect him to be that close
oh my God
that looks really cool let's see lad is
looking fine oh my God that is so cool
um I'm a little intimidated I'm not
gonna lie very very intimidated
um
he's a big lad he's got very nice
muscles I've Got Friends this big
oh my God the chains are so cool I love
the teeth the tusks turned out really
good I love you put real hair on it
though that's amazing I didn't expect
him to be that close as well I was like
oh his hair is so gorgeous oh my God it
is so cool so here he is my buddy
grommash bigger in person than you might
imagine 20 tubs a month of clay I've
used every single tub but with that said
I have to say this is my favorite video
I've made in ages this is just so much
fun it was a lot of work so I really
hope you've enjoyed it and if you have
please hit that like button I know you
hear that all the time I say it I'm like
I've heard that all the time but it
really makes a huge difference and if
you like seeing videos like this
subscribe for more go on click that
subscribe button you know one of my
grandma's angry
in the meantime before my next video
make sure to go over to tabletop time to
check out the video where we made the
Lions pride in the gold chicken from
Warcraft until next time I'll see you
later later
[Music]